c'est tout moment il est temps pour nous
d'écouter la colère du peuple s'est
creusé par la voix est l'organe du
procureur général de la république des
proches française
[Musique]
et c'est pas de la musique populaire
sahraouie populaire la peine de mort
c'est très populaire
[Musique]
merci georges un bol c'était très beau
françaises français belges belge
manouche manouche mon président mon
chien mon cher ténors du fado famélique
cher miss nougat on a oublié de noter
que messing à 66 et lé 15 heures à 4,24
pardon termisme louga et douce kazatchok
honnête la fleur d'oranger
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour tous les bidons
[Applaudissements]
de poids ou quoi bon 12 ces questions de
poids 12 12
mes oreilles ça va pas mal an avant en
arizona dans la tête avant toute chose
mesdames et messieurs monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
jurés avant toute chose je voudrais
signaler que cette émission devant être
diffusée le 11 mai prochain c'est à dire
au lendemain du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
je voudrais au nom de la procure tout
entière et en mon nom personnel félicité
le président de la république
[Musique]
la france ne s'y est pas trompée elle
avait la france avait à choisir entre la
redondance boursouflé de la vieille
droite et la ringardise opportuniste de
la vieille gauche elle a choisi le
meilleur bravo vivre mais quittons
l'occident et partons à lorient pêcher
la crevette pardon quittons l'occident
et partons pour lorient empêcher le
hareng après enrico macias c'est en rika
zaraï que nous avons condamné
aujourd'hui en notre âme et conscience
nous allons juger
le problème c'est que nous allons juger
aujourd'hui en votre âme et conscience
avant de lui couper la tête
la tâche qui m'incombe aujourd'hui est
rude mesdames et messieurs les jurés car
enfin je vous le demande point nous
avons qui tu peux en vouloir à cet
adorable jeune femme brune dont les yeux
de blondes
à vingt brûle brûle et blanc à la fois
cette jeune femme brune décolorés dont
les yeux de velours de l'estomac dont
dans les yeux velouté de champignons
dans les yeux sont plantés comme moi
même je me plante actuellement pas les
attaques personnelles
sinon je vais parler de ses fesses moi
je vous en prie excusez moi cette femme
n'est point mauvaise hélas jeudi hélas
car une fois de plus m rigaud je risque
de vous ôter la gousse d'ail crû de la
bouche en accablant pas votre cliente
mme hégo mais est ce ma faute à moi mon
petit luis vous permettez vous appelle
oui est ce ma faute à moi si lisa
racaille est une sainte femme gmi
comment risa s'écaille j'aime y perd
j'ai mis personnellement la main à son
riz qu l'invité
et je n'y ai trouvé que de bonnes
raisons de lui pardonner son crime avant
de l'exécuter
par exemple la été élue miss nougat à
montélimar en 60 cas mais qui vous a
raconté s'est hissé dans votre
curriculum le 2 août 1964 n'importe qui
n'importe qui ne peut pas être élue miss
nous garde il faut chaud c'est au moins
du 44 et ce n'est pas tout les épreuves
pratiques auxquelles sont soumis les
candidates au titre de miss nougat sont
épuisants greta marmaille est trop
modeste pour vous la voix leur sélection
des jurés mais moi qui vous parle je
connais très bien montélimar j'ai une
camarade qui habite sur la colline nov
et je puis en témoigner c'est très
fatigant de monthelie mais à montélimar
oui oui rina kai kai a bien mérité son
titre de miss louga oui mais c'est le
même régime que monsieur le président
exactement
qui sait de quel autre titre horde
honorifique elle aurait pu honorer la
france si au lieu d'aller à montélimar
elle était allée à francfort ou et
toulouse
qui sait quel trophée elle ou lui
rapporter de cambrai est ce que
quelqu'un ici
est ce que quelqu'un dans cette salle m
le boudin orientale
attention il ne faut pas confondre le
bouddha orientale et le boudin antillais
que mireille mathieu a rendu célèbre
depuis le début de sa puberté en 56 le
bouddha orientale lui peut être
consommée aussi bien à tel-aviv sous la
braise qu'à beyrouth sous les bombes il
s'agit d'un boudin à base de cheval et
des pistes variées très savoureux et
très faciles à préparer alors vous
prenez un cheval fourbus à la fin d'une
corrida ou du prix bride abattue voulu
enfoncer 50 kilos de piment rouge dans
le fondement sel poivre thym laurier une
pincée de coriandre
puis vous saignez votre cheval blanc en
profitant de son inattention pendant
qu'yves pendant qu'ils voulaient chef
actuellement la main de sa grosse langue
râpeuse par exemple le sang ainsi obtenu
gorges et les senteurs sauvage des
épices de lorient est additionnée de
cette fois son volume d'anisette pur
sera très appréciée des petits et des
grands
à l'heure de l'apéritif à ce propos je
me rappelle une cuite au bout d'un
cheval en israël avec luis rego qu'elle
biture à l'origine nous étions allés là
bas en israël pour rigoler le temps d'un
week-end luis kir et celle des trésors
d'idées géniales sous son crâne de piaf
prématurément racornie par la sécheresse
ibérique
puis il y avait eu l'idée de me traîner
en israël à samedi le jour où dit-il
on se marre le plus là bas mais qu'est
ce qu'on va [ __ ] en israël qu'est ce
qu'on va [ __ ] ici m'inquiétais jean
débarquant de l'avion
on va se fendre la gueule dit luis tu
sais quoi on veut organiser un pogrom
un quoi à tel-aviv métaux neige en fait
ce n'était pas une idée terrible on a
commencé par coller sur les vitrines des
commerçants des petites affiches
marrante
on avait écrit tu dors les juifs le bide
limpide j'ai même cru discerner quelle
qui regardent au style parmi la
population autochtone qu'à cela ne
tienne lancé j'avais qu'optimiste vient
mon cher luis tu je connais un
restaurant ou en sert un délicieux
boudin orientale à nous allons nous
sustenter mon cher luis tu veux manger
épicé
j'aimerais mieux puis c'est d'abord le
sait que vous représentez le parquet
d'en face à un peu pas il ya des jours
où les glissant c'est ainsi que monsieur
rigaud et moi déguste un ensemble un
délicieux boon orientale et de
savoureuses brochette de testicules de
mouton
je vous recommande le restaurant ça
s'appelle les choses de lévis
[Applaudissements]
sa selle saint-siège service on peut
préparer soi-même ses brochettes sympa
lundi vers lévis vous donne à l'entrée
une grande brochette vous allez dans
l'enclos qui est derrière le restaurant
où paissent des moutons ses moutons les
décousu ce coup de fil blanc c'est une
race spéciale les coups de fil blanc
sait ils sont tous blancs avec deux
énormes aux yeux bleus voilà vous avez
droit ainsi des sticks ulpat brochettes
alors vous vous mettez les trois boutons
côte à côte que vous tendez la brochette
comme une baïonnette et c'est encore
plus difficile que la recette de l'intro
shadé van orman en tout cas j'ai lu que
rika zaraï ne savait pas nager inutile
de rougir la guillotine
y'a qu'à la noyée en lui ajoutant cette
fois son volume d'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]